Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Jake:大成功
Jake: Big success
Lucia: 所以所以所以外面是可以了是吗
Lucia: So, so, so, the outside is ready, right?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yes
Jake:算是可以了
Jake: It's pretty much ready
Jake:温度起来了
Jake: The temperature is up
Jake:火还没完全着完
Jake: The fire isn't fully lit yet
Jake:可以开始考了就是
Jake: We can start grilling now
Tasha: 杯子
Tasha: Cup
Tasha: 杯子杯子
Tasha: Cup, cup
Lucia: 哦我怎么老是找不到东西呢
Lucia: Oh, why do I always lose things?
Lucia: 放10个
Lucia: Put 10
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Tasha: 12个也行
Tasha: 12 works too
Tasha: 10个吧不知道
Tasha: Let's put 10, I don't know
Lucia: 行万一一会到的多了再放
Lucia: Okay, if we need more, we'll add later
Lucia: 哎呀我放12个吧因为刚好排三排
Lucia: Oh, I'll put 12 because it fits in 3 rows
Jake:好看对挺好
Jake: Looks good, yeah, it's nice
Lucia: 强迫症发作
Lucia: My OCD is kicking in
Jake:我来把芒果给干掉
Jake: I'll take care of the mango
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:我放在哪了找个碗
Jake: Where did I put it, find a bowl
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it
Tasha: 你可以每个里面放3块3
Tasha: You can put 3 pieces in each
Tasha: 嗯铺个底
Tasha: Hmm, as the base
Tasha: 我看铺个底要多少个好吧
Tasha: Let me see how many we need for the base, okay
Tasha: 这么多吧
Tasha: This much, I guess
Tasha: 大概123 哈哈
Tasha: About 123, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈行我还是数数123456
Lucia: Hahaha, okay, let me count, 123456
Tasha: 好就铺个底就行这样子
Tasha: Alright, just enough for the base
Tasha: 要不来倒主厨
Tasha: How about you be the chef?
Jake:哈哈我
Jake: Haha, me?
Jake:我怎么敢
Jake: How could I dare?
Jake:哎倒什么呀
Jake: What should I pour?
Tasha: 就把它倒进去就行
Tasha: Just pour it in
Jake:好好行
Jake: Okay, okay, sure
Jake:我试试倒多少啊
Jake: How much should I pour?
Jake:三分之几
Jake: About a third?
Tasha: 倒个七八分满就行
Tasha: Pour it about 70-80% full
Tasha: 但是要 12个
Tasha: But make sure it's 12
Jake:三分之
Jake: One-third of
Tasha: 你要倒均匀点吗
Tasha: Do you want to pour it evenly?
Lucia: 咦多了
Lucia: Oh, too much.
Jake:好那我就慢慢倒
Jake: Okay, I'll pour it slowly then.
Tasha: 不着急要等这个烤出来他才能到
Tasha: No rush, we need to wait for this to bake before we can continue.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, got it.
Tasha: 他才能进
Tasha: Then we can start the next batch.
Tasha: 进下一锅
Tasha: Start the next batch.
Jake:懂了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:那我还是干芒果
Jake: Then I'll still use the dried mango.
Jake:这芒果不软的
Jake: This mango isn't soft.
Tasha: 虽然不软
Tasha: Although it's not soft,
Tasha: 但是我感觉它看起来有啊
Tasha: I think it looks like
Tasha: 好像已经有点
Tasha: It's already a bit
Lucia: 稍微有点那个氧化了一样
Lucia: It looks a bit oxidized.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:可能就是这种品种吧
Jake: Maybe it's just this variety.
Jake:有水果刀吗
Jake: Do we have a fruit knife?
Jake:用菜刀也行吧
Jake: A kitchen knife will do too.
Tasha: 嗯要求不要太过分
Tasha: Yeah, don't be too picky.
Jake:这不过分吧
Jake: That's not too much to ask, right?
Jake:有水果捞切芒果
Jake: We have fruit salad, cut the mango.
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: That's about right.
Tasha: 进入完全不讲究状态
Tasha: We've reached the "don't care" stage.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 咖啡豆啊
Katrina: Coffee beans?
Tasha: 呃巧克力
Tasha: Uh, chocolate.
Lucia: 巧克力啊没事不用对不起
Lucia: Chocolate? It's okay, no need to apologize.
Katrina: 哦哦对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Katrina: 巧克力
Katrina: Chocolate.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我
Katrina: Hahaha, I
Katrina: 我的生活常识太匮乏
Katrina: I really lack common sense.
Lucia: 哇这巧克力好香啊
Lucia: Wow, this chocolate smells so good.
Lucia: 可以吃一个吗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I eat one? Hahaha.
Tasha: 可以啊他就是纯巧克力黑巧58
Tasha: Sure, it's pure dark chocolate, 58%.
Katrina: 这能扔了不
Katrina: Can I throw this away?
Katrina: 感觉第一天
Katrina: Feels like it's the first day.
Lucia: 要先吃一片吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Should I eat a piece first? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈我不要
Tasha: Haha, not for me.
Lucia: 宇轩要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to eat a piece first?
Katrina: 我尝一个
Katrina: I'll try one.
Lucia: 喂你吧要不哈哈哈
Lucia: Should I feed you? Haha.
Katrina: 好的你喂我吧
Katrina: Sure, you can feed me.
Lucia: 健康要先吃一片吗
Lucia: JianKang, do you want to eat a piece first?
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 我就不喂你了
Lucia: I won't feed you though.
Lucia: 自己可以给你倒出来哈哈
Lucia: You can pour it out yourself. Haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎呀我再来一片
Lucia: Oh, I'll have another piece.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这叫什么呀
Jake: What's this called?
Tasha: 一定要认准这个牌子
Tasha: Make sure to recognize this brand.
Tasha: 百丽
Tasha: Belle.
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:嗯确实不太好端
Jake: Hmm, it's actually not easy to hold.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他突然文盲哈哈哈哈不不不
Lucia: Haha, he suddenly became illiterate. Hahaha, no, no.
Tasha: 不愧是高材生
Tasha: No wonder he's a top student.
Tasha: 说话就是这么有水平
Tasha: He speaks so eloquently.
Tasha: 我来切吧
Tasha: I'll cut it.
Tasha: 你去忙那个
Tasha: You go handle that.
Tasha: 好我先跟你
Tasha: Alright, I'll start with you.
Tasha: 你菜板忙
Tasha: Your cutting board is so busy.
Tasha: 洗了吗怎么感觉这么脏
Tasha: Did you wash it? It looks so dirty.
Jake:加点洋葱味问题不大
Jake: Adding some onion flavor won't be a big problem.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Tasha: Haha, why is this cutting board so dirty?
Katrina: 哇噻哇噻哇噻
Katrina: Wow, wow, wow.
Jake:这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Jake: Why is this cutting board so dirty?
Tasha: 你这菜刀洗了吗
Tasha: Did you wash this knife?
Jake:菜刀洗了
Jake: The knife is washed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:板是蒜和洋葱
Jake: The board has garlic and onion on it.
Jake:对哇不要蒜
Jake: Right, no garlic.
Lucia: 哇不要蒜
Lucia: Wow, no garlic.
Lucia: 蒜沾到水果上面味道很大的
Lucia: Garlic on the fruit would make it taste strong.
Lucia: 洋葱可能还好一点
Lucia: Onion might be a bit better.
Tasha: 你太过分了
Tasha: You're too much.
Shure: 稍等
Shure: Hold on.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 把水果也从洗了
Tasha: Also, wash the fruits
Jake:好好水果我也洗一洗
Jake: Alright, I'll wash the fruits too
Lucia: 没事幸好它还没切开
Lucia: It's fine, luckily it wasn't cut yet
Lucia: 要蒜味要沾到水果上真的特别难消掉
Lucia: If the garlic flavor gets on the fruit, it's really hard to get rid of
Lucia: 就是你就会吃到那个味道
Lucia: You'll end up tasting it
Jake:哈哈好的
Jake: Haha, okay
Lucia: 就是葱不是葱
Lucia: It's not green onions
Lucia: 蒜瓣西瓜吃过吗
Lucia: Have you ever had garlic watermelon?
Lucia: 哈哈哈蒜瓣西瓜对我
Lucia: Hahaha, garlic watermelon, right
Jake:蒜瓣西瓜就是把蒜给绞西瓜汁里
Jake: Garlic watermelon is like blending garlic into watermelon juice
Lucia: 没有就有一回
Lucia: No, just once
Tasha: 就是切切的刀上面有蒜味
Tasha: It was just that the knife had garlic on it
Lucia: 我们家里忘记对我们家切过蒜的刀
Lucia: We forgot at home, we used the knife that cut garlic
Jake:哦哦切刀刀上哦
Jake: Oh, oh, the knife had garlic on it
Lucia: 忘记了然后直接切的瓜
Lucia: We forgot and just cut the watermelon
Lucia: 然后那个味道特别可怕
Lucia: And the taste was terrible
Jake:用什么东西泡呀
Jake: What did you soak it with?
Tasha: 这肉
Tasha: This meat
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it
Katrina: 这怎么洗嘞
Katrina: How do you wash this?
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This one is fine
Lucia: 嗯我试试看
Lucia: Hmm, let me try
Tasha: 您要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Jake:我可以要
Jake: I can take it
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Katrina: 我的认知里好像没有洗青菜这个选
Katrina: I don't think washing vegetables was an option in my knowledge
Tasha: 就他可以
Tasha: He can do it
Shure: 直接放上面了
Shure: Just put it on top
Tasha: 阻断他流
Tasha: Block the flow
Lucia: 生菜确实一般
Lucia: Lettuce is usually
Shure: 卧槽你虎皮
Shure: Whoa, you overcooked it
Lucia: 可能都直接在这放一下好了
Lucia: Maybe just leave it here for a bit
Tasha: 好您试
Tasha: Okay, you try
Tasha: 不听
Tasha: Not listening
Katrina: 嗯应该是掰开了
Katrina: Hmm, it should be broken apart
Jake:是不是有点太保守了
Jake: Is it a bit too conservative?
Lucia: 把盘拿大点的
Lucia: Get a bigger plate
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then
Jake:我先少弄点啊
Jake: I'll start with a little bit first.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Jake:好我保守一点保守一点
Jake: Alright, I'll be conservative, be conservative.
Tasha: 这个有点多了吧
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too much?
Tasha: 不是很保守吗
Tasha: I thought you were being conservative?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, true.
Jake:这个多吗
Jake: Is this too much?
Tasha: 这正常吧
Tasha: This seems normal.
Tasha: 我觉最高就这么高就行了
Tasha: I think the highest it should go is just this high.
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: Be conservative, be conservative.
Jake:太吵了哎
Jake: It's too noisy, hey.
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: Be conservative, be conservative.
Jake:诶诶诶诶诶诶别
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, don't.
Jake:别动啊别动啊诶
Jake: Don't move, don't move, hey.
Jake:我可能会了
Jake: I might get it.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 有合关发牌
Tasha: It's about dealing cards.
Tasha: 有杨老师在线切蛋糕液
Tasha: It's like having Mr. Yang cutting the cake live.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿是吧
Tasha: Hehehe, right?
Jake:对哎感觉不错
Jake: Yeah, it feels pretty good.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:挺好玩
Jake: It's pretty fun.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好玩多玩会
Tasha: It's fun, let's play a bit more.
Tasha: 哎这个会不会太过分了
Tasha: Hey, isn't this too much?
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:我怕最后不够了
Jake: I'm afraid there won't be enough at the end.
Lucia: 你干了什么
Lucia: What did you do?
Jake:还好还好就是呃呃尽量让他均匀
Jake: It's alright, it's alright, just trying to make it even.
Jake:但是可能没那么均匀
Jake: But it might not be that even.
Tasha: 你看第一个和这个均匀吗
Tasha: Does the first one and this one look even?
Jake:哎一会再补一补啊补一补
Jake: Hey, we'll fix it up later, fix it up.
Lucia: 你做了什么伤天害理的事
Lucia: What horrible thing did you do?
Jake:补一补补一补
Jake: Fix it up, fix it up.
Jake:就是这个分配不均
Jake: It's just that the distribution isn't even.
Tasha: 这个这个这个
Tasha: This, this, this.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha.
Tasha: 不患寡患不均
Tasha: It's not about having less, but about fairness.
Lucia: 不患寡而患不均
Lucia: It's not about having less, but about fairness.
Jake:对就是现在这既既寡又不均
Jake: Yes, it's just that it's both scarce and uneven.
Lucia: 弃寡又不均
Lucia: Scarce and uneven.
Tasha: 这个放在烤箱面前
Tasha: Put this in front of the oven.
Tasha: 会不会把它水分给烤了
Tasha: Will it dry out the moisture?
Lucia: 我刚也在这么想
Lucia: I was just thinking the same.
Lucia: 但是我好像暂时没找到别的地方
Lucia: But I haven't found another place for it.
Lucia: 我打算快点洗
Lucia: I'll wash it quickly.
Tasha: 这个厨房就这么小对
Tasha: This kitchen is so small, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 咱们人比较多
Lucia: We have a lot of people.
Lucia: 这厨房有点太小了
Lucia: This kitchen is a bit too small.
Lucia: 这么大厨房我觉得两三个人还行
Lucia: For a kitchen this size, two or three people is fine.
Lucia: 再多就东西会放不下
Lucia: Any more and there won't be enough space.
Tasha: 还有十几分钟这我就烤好了
Tasha: In about ten minutes, this will be done baking.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那咱外面的进度咋样
Lucia: So how's the progress outside?
Jake:呃进度
Jake: Uh, progress...
Jake:不知道啊反正5分钟之前进度是0
Jake: I don't know, five minutes ago the progress was zero.
Lucia: 说明他们进度与指数函数性增长
Lucia: That means their progress is growing exponentially.
Jake:是的是是这么回事
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Jake:是一个呃
Jake: It is a, uh...
Tasha: 维护秀是吧
Tasha: Maintenance show, right?
Jake:应该就是就火点着了
Jake: Should be, the fire is lit.
Jake:然后就可以开始了
Jake: Then we can start.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Tasha: OK火点着了
Tasha: Okay, the fire is lit.
Lucia: 火点着这是个原爆点
Lucia: The fire is lit, this is the starting point.
Tasha: 是个原爆点是的
Tasha: It's the starting point, yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 谁会成为我们的普罗米修斯呢
Lucia: Who will be our Prometheus?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:刚刚特意买了一个
Jake: Just bought one specifically.
Jake:就是一瓶酒精然后全撒上去了没有用
Jake: A bottle of alcohol, then poured it all on, didn't work.
Jake:那个碳比较难点
Jake: The charcoal is hard to light.
Jake:碳质量一般
Jake: The quality of the charcoal is average.
Lucia: 它接触氧的面积会比较大一点
Lucia: The contact area with oxygen will be larger.
Jake:听起来是这样
Jake: Sounds like it.
Jake:一只筷子
Jake: One chopstick.
Katrina: 哎我们只有这几双筷子
Katrina: Hey, we only have these few pairs of chopsticks.
Katrina: 我也好奇
Katrina: I'm curious too
Katrina: 你的那个
Katrina: About yours
Lucia: 哎还行吧
Lucia: Oh, it's okay
Jake:对啊可好了
Jake: Yeah, it's really good
Tasha: 你是刚才就是再分配了一下吗
Tasha: Did you just redistribute it?
Jake:对对对再分配
Jake: Yeah, yeah, redistributed
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 二次分配
Tasha: Second redistribution
Jake:哈哈哈是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Jake:就和谐了嘛
Jake: Now it's harmonious
Jake:现在很和谐
Jake: Very harmonious now
Jake:扶贫现在是
Jake: The poverty alleviation now is
Jake:看看好现在全面脱贫
Jake: Look, now it's complete poverty eradication
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈可以吧
Jake: Hahaha, is that okay?
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Hahaha, dying of laughter
Lucia: 好家伙
Lucia: Oh my
Jake:怎么样和谐
Jake: How's that, harmonious?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good
Lucia: 可以非常好
Lucia: Very good
Tasha: 你看有的很好
Tasha: You see, some are really good
Jake:啊还是有一些先富的人是吧
Jake: Ah, there are still some who got rich first, right?
Lucia: 哎我觉得里面的这些叶子很干净
Lucia: Hey, I think these leaves inside are very clean
Tasha: 不是你看这上面有很多气泡看到了吗
Tasha: No, look, there are many bubbles on top, do you see them?
Tasha: 啊就这样子
Tasha: Ah, just like this
Jake:哦那我每个都打一会
Jake: Oh, then I'll hit each one for a while
Tasha: 就是因为你可能弄得太低了
Tasha: It's because you might have set it too low
Tasha: 然后他的气泡就会产生
Tasha: And then the bubbles would form
Tasha: 这样子会导致他很多空心的就不太
Tasha: This would cause a lot of hollow areas, so it's not
Jake:就不太明白哎
Jake: I don't quite understand
Tasha: 哎这个
Tasha: Ah, this
Jake:这个这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with this
Jake:这太少了啊
Jake: This is too little
Shure: 要不然你用这个夹子
Shure: Why don't you use this clipper
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's okay
Jake:没事还是有低保户
Jake: It's okay, there are still people on welfare
Tasha: 嗯对你把有气泡的就这样子震一震
Tasha: Yeah, you just shake the ones with bubbles like this
Lucia: 什么历史遗留问题是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Some historical leftover issues, right? Hahaha
Shure: 行看着吧
Shure: Alright, let's see.
Jake:哈哈哈对是地质疑的问题
Jake: Hahaha, yes, it's a question of doubt.
Shure: 感觉差不多
Shure: Feels about right.
Shure: 就翻一翻
Shure: Just flip it over.
Tasha: 不然不然它不好吃就不够松软
Tasha: Otherwise, it won't be good, not soft enough.
Jake:哦我每个都摔一摔吧
Jake: Oh, should I shake each one?
Jake:嗯那这个我怎么加上呢
Jake: Hmm, how do I add this?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:就有一个小的是吧
Jake: There's a small one, right?
Tasha: 算了吧
Tasha: Forget it.
Tasha: 中国总有贫困地区的
Tasha: There are always poor areas in China. 社会问题
Lucia: 要遵循事物的发展规律吗
Lucia: Should we follow the development rules?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 这个还要再洗一下
Tasha: This needs to be washed again.
Lucia: 哈怎么了
Lucia: Haha, what's up?
Lucia: 你以为我个人专业
Lucia: You think I'm a professional?
Jake:哈哈哈专业太专业了
Jake: Hahaha, too professional.
Lucia: 个人简历的专业是白写的哈
Lucia: My resume's specialty was written in vain, haha.
Jake:这个你要不写个报告吧
Jake: How about you write a report?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈怎么了
Jake: Hahaha, what's up?
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Cook it a bit longer.
Tasha: 没事没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Jake:撒了
Jake: It spilled.
Tasha: 等会再用
Tasha: Use it later.
Tasha: 这部分谁都不要碰
Tasha: No one touch this part.
Jake:那谁敢碰啊
Jake: Who would dare touch it?
Lucia: 这玩意我先给他们端出去吧
Lucia: I'll take this out to them first.
Lucia: 要出去吗
Lucia: Should I take it out?
Lucia: 来看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Lucia: 别别菜叶子吹干了
Lucia: No, no, the leaves will dry out.
Tasha: 干什么呢干什么呢干什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing, what are you doing, what are you doing?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我要干嘛
Tasha: What am I doing?
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:你要干嘛你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Lucia: 这个菜现在用得到吗
Lucia: Do we need to use this vegetable now?
Lucia: 如果暂时用不到我就先放回去
Lucia: If not, I'll put it back.
Tasha: 你怎么这么凶
Tasha: Why are you so fierce?
Jake:你要干嘛啊
Jake: What are you doing?
Lucia: 一会再拿出来
Tasha: 哈哈哈你要不就切芒果吧别再摔了
Tasha: Hahaha, why don't you just cut the mango instead of dropping it again.
Jake:哈哈哈对不起对不起
Jake: Hahaha, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 桌上我怕外面灰大一会就
Lucia: I'm worried about the dust outside, so let's...
Jake:为啥可以了
Jake: Why not? It's fine.
Tasha: 好了可以了哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, it's fine, hahaha.
Jake:我挺喜欢摔的
Jake: I actually like dropping things.
Jake:因为里面有一些气泡
Jake: Because there are some bubbles inside.
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: It still needs me.
Tasha: 他需要你好
Tasha: It needs you, alright.
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: It still needs me.
Jake:对他还需要
Jake: Yes, it still needs...
Jake:我我觉得我还可以
Jake: I think I can still...
Jake:有贡献的地方他还需要我
Jake: Contribute, it still needs me.
Lucia: 那煤能给它敲碎吗
Lucia: Can we break the coal?
Lucia: 我感觉那么大一块确实不太不太好
Lucia: I feel like it's too big, really not convenient.
Tasha: 哎我靠
Tasha: Oh my god!
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: What?
Jake:不能这么干是吧
Jake: We can't do it like this, right?
Tasha: 呃没必要
Tasha: Uhh, no need.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, alright.
Tasha: 可以了可以了
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 干嘛呢接下来
Tasha: What are we doing next?
Jake:不不有气泡
Jake: No, no, there are bubbles.
Tasha: 去切去
Tasha: Go cut it.
Jake:真有气泡
Jake: There really are bubbles.
Tasha: 真没必要了
Tasha: It's really not necessary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈这为什么感觉有
Jake: Why does it feel like there's...
Jake:有红的颜色
Jake: A red color?
Jake:是这个油
Jake: Is it the oil?
Tasha: 巧克力可能溶溶了一些可以了
Tasha: Maybe the chocolate melted a bit, it's fine.
Jake:你看这个是气泡吧
Jake: Look, this is a bubble, right?
Lucia: 这哪里有红的
Lucia: Where is the red?
Jake:哈哈哈哈有这种夸赞吗
Jake: Hahahaha, is this a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你是不是想说这么明显
Lucia: Hahaha, are you saying it's so obvious?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是啊
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:不是不是我说有这种夸赞
Jake: No, no, I'm saying, is this a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:不是就是
Jake: No, it's just that...
Lucia: 真是一种夸赞
Lucia: It's really a compliment.
Lucia: 你学画画很厉害的
Lucia: You're really good at drawing.
Lucia: 会哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Jake:好这么回事
Jake: Oh, I get it now.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:可能是我这个眼线的反射
Jake: Maybe it's the reflection of my eyeliner.
Jake:我怎么切怎么切
Jake: How should I cut this?
Tasha: 怎么切直直接切就行
Tasha: Just cut it straight, that's fine.
Jake:好我就切
Jake: Alright, I'll cut it.
Jake:行我直接切
Jake: Okay, I'll cut it directly.
Lucia: 另外这棵菜哎呀
Lucia: Also, this vegetable, oh dear.
Lucia: 我都在想要不等他们进度再再来点
Lucia: I'm thinking, maybe we should wait for their progress and then add some more.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我再洗
Lucia: I'll wash more.
Jake:楼上其实可以整整俩整板下来
Jake: Actually, we could get two whole plates from upstairs.
Lucia: 菜这东西
Lucia: Vegetables, you know...
Jake:但是还没必要
Jake: But it's not necessary.
Lucia: 如果洗了就不能就不太能放了
Lucia: Once you wash them, you can't store them well.
Lucia: 万一是吧
Lucia: Just in case, you know.
Lucia: 我们退一万步讲
Lucia: Let's think about the worst-case scenario.
Jake:对万一今天他就打不着了哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, what if today he can't make it. Haha.
Lucia: 今天晚对哈哈
Lucia: Tonight, yeah. Haha.
Jake:退一百步就是哈哈哈
Jake: Let's take a hundred steps back. Haha.
Tasha: 我买的我买的
Tasha: I bought it, I bought it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Tasha: The oven thermometer.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: Is this it?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my.
Tasha: 竟然真的是
Tasha: It really is.
Lucia: 这个是不是要洗啊这个对对对
Lucia: Does this need to be washed? Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 不是要洗啊
Tasha: Doesn't it need washing?
Tasha: 是吗对对对
Tasha: Right, right.
Tasha: 虽然很危险
Tasha: Even though it's risky.
Lucia: 哎呀就喜欢这种没有油的东西
Lucia: Oh dear, I just love things without oil.
Lucia: 一旦沾上油就可难洗老难洗
Lucia: Once it gets oily, it's so hard to clean, really hard.
Lucia: 我靠我不会又弄衣服了吧
Lucia: Oh no, did I get my clothes dirty again?
Jake:我感觉好像不
Jake: I feel like no...
Jake:好像切了出来怎么没什么肉啊
Jake: I cut it, but there doesn't seem to be much meat.
Lucia: 因为皮上沾的太多了
Lucia: Because there was too much stuck to the skin.
Jake:我来
Jake: I'll do it.
Tasha: 给你们洗个碟
Tasha: Let me wash a dish for you.
Jake:我来我来研究研究
Jake: I'll do it, I'll study it.
Lucia: 不是您这个的正确打开方法
Lucia: This is not the correct way to open it.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 哎sorry啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Tasha: 不用sorry吧
Tasha: No need to say sorry.
Tasha: 给您洗个碟
Tasha: Let me wash a dish for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 您想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: You can cut it however you like.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 你这个的正确打开方式
Lucia: The correct way to open it is...
Lucia: 现在变成了这样
Lucia: It has become like this now.
Tasha: 不是这个里面没盒吗
Tasha: Isn't there a box inside?
Lucia: 我给你我给你演示一下啊哈哈
Lucia: Let me show you, haha.
Jake:有有有还没搞定呢试一下啊
Jake: Yes, yes, still not done yet, let's try it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈好很正确
Jake: Haha, good, very correct.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈你知道吗
Lucia: Haha, you know?
Jake:哈哈哈我也来正确一下
Jake: Haha, let me do it correctly too.
Lucia: 打开包成了这样的
Lucia: Open the package, it turned out like this.
Jake:好好好会了会了我也会了
Jake: Okay, okay, I've got it, I've got it.
Tasha: 我也会的
Tasha: I got it too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这个应该不是你切的问题
Lucia: This isn't about how you cut it.
Tasha: 就有的芒果它就是皮比较容易粘肉
Tasha: Some mangoes have skins that stick to the flesh easily.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:就应该这么打开
Jake: It should be opened like this.
Lucia: 对秉承着我们不浪费的原则
Lucia: Yes, following our principle of not wasting.
Lucia: 就也可以先这样吃一下
Lucia: You can also eat it like this first.
Lucia: 然后那部分的用来用来当馅
Lucia: Then use the rest as filling.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 外面是不是有什么进展了
Lucia: Is there any progress outside?
Lucia: 我好像听见了碗筷的声音
Lucia: I think I heard the sound of dishes.
Lucia:   哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 给孩子饿成啥了
Tasha: The kid must be starving.
Jake:在敲是吧
Jake: They're knocking, right?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他们可能只是单纯的就是在把碗筷
Lucia: They might just be simply moving the dishes
Jake:奏乐哈哈哈接
Jake: Playing music, hahaha, continue
Lucia: 哈哈哈从一个地方搬到另一个地方
Lucia: Hahaha, from one place to another
Jake:好吧好吧虽然打不着继续奏乐
Jake: Alright, alright, even though we can't hit it, keep playing the music
Jake:接着走位
Jake: Keep moving
Tasha: 他就烤好了
Tasha: It's done roasting
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Lucia: 我当时想问能不能把那个碳
Lucia: I was thinking of asking if we could break the charcoal
Lucia: 比如说怎么着给它敲
Lucia: Like, how do we break it
Lucia: 敲碎一点
Lucia: Break it into smaller pieces
Jake:不要切到手呀
Jake: Don't cut your hand
Jake:那我这个会这个知道
Jake: I know how to do this
Jake:这个多少知道一点
Jake: I know a bit about this
Tasha: 您真的不用争取用一下碘伏了
Tasha: You really don't need to use iodine
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不用争取
Lucia: Hahaha, you don't need to fight over this
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈我尽力
Jake: Hahaha, I'll try my best
Lucia: 这真不用争取
Lucia: You really don't need to fight over this
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 您争取不用
Lucia: Try not to use it
Jake:好争取不用
Jake: Okay, I'll try not to use it
Jake:这怎么下来
Jake: How do I get this down
Tasha: 杨老师你把这盘弄这么脏
Tasha: Mr. Yang, you made this plate so dirty
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh
Jake:啊哪个盘啊对不起
Jake: Ah, which plate? Sorry
Lucia: 烤箱盘
Lucia: The oven tray
Tasha: 拿个纸吧
Tasha: Get some paper
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 这个干净的
Lucia: This one's clean
Lucia: 我刚只是冲了手的时候擦了一下水
Lucia: I just wiped my hands with it after rinsing them
Lucia: 哎这为啥有
Lucia: Hey, why is there
Lucia: 一个撒了的
Lucia: Something spilled
Tasha: 呃不要碰
Tasha: Uh, don't touch it
Tasha: 等会我们还要弄进去
Tasha: We'll need to put it back later
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈这是干净的
Tasha: Hahaha, this one's clean
Lucia: 好的好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay
Tasha: 还还差纸还差纸
Tasha: Still need more paper, still need more paper
Lucia: 擦盘子是吧
Lucia: Wiping the plate, right?
Lucia: 反正是那就用昨天肯德基还是啥
Lucia: Anyway, let's use the KFC from yesterday or whatever.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 这纸这纸
Lucia: This paper, this paper.
Lucia: 为啥是这样
Lucia: Why is it like this?
Lucia: 有点太脏了
Lucia: It's a bit too dirty.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Tasha: 主要这个烤盘烤箱不是借的吗
Tasha: Mainly because this baking tray, wasn't it borrowed?
Tasha: 啊环的时候要是烤的这么
Tasha: If we bake it like this...
Alice:在这熄火一会中毒了
Alice: If we turn off the heat here, we might get poisoned.
Tasha: 就是都粘在这上面了
Tasha: It's all sticking to this.
Tasha: 就烤完之后就不好清理了对
Tasha: After baking, it will be hard to clean, right?
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: That's it.
Shure: 这应该也是着了吧
Shure: This should be burnt too, right?
Jake:再来一个
Jake: Another one.
Alice:我们今天吃原味的
Alice: We're having the original flavor today.
Jake:哎哪去了
Jake: Oh, where did it go?
Lucia: 这是几个切出来的呀
Lucia: How many were cut out from this?
Jake:这是一个切出来的
Jake: This was cut from one.
Lucia: 那还行那还行
Lucia: That's fine then.
Lucia: 我以为是俩呢
Lucia: I thought it was two.
Jake:哈哈哈被吃的太多了
Jake: Haha, it got eaten too much.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈没关系继续吃
Jake: Haha, no worries, keep eating.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:准备好了吗
Jake: Ready?
Jake:准备吃啊
Jake: Ready to eat?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Tasha: OK还挺准的呢
Tasha: OK, it's quite accurate.
Tasha: 这个温度
Tasha: This temperature.
Lucia: 薇薇可以吃芒果了
Lucia: Tasha can eat mangoes now.
Tasha: 不是你一个芒果就算切出这么多
Tasha: But did you cut all this from just one mango?
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我以为是两个切的呢
Tasha: I thought it was cut from two.
Tasha: 我还想挺不错的呢
Tasha: I thought it was pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好那那我再切一个
Jake: Alright, then I'll cut another one.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 毕竟刚才那个皮上沾了很多
Lucia: After all, the skin had a lot on it.
Jake:这个皮上应该也沾不少
Jake: This skin should have a lot too.
Lucia: 如果有水果刀可以那样削着皮切
Tasha: 但是咱家没有
Tasha: 我们不是有个削皮刀吗
Lucia: 小心手
Tasha: 好像不行
Lucia: 削对
Lucia: 削一套好
Lucia: 削不了这个
Lucia: 只能削红薯土豆
Jake:来试试用一些手法
Tasha: 什么手法秘制
Jake:这个就是
Jake:慢一点
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: 辣椒面是
Tasha: 不知道拿去
Lucia: 呃外面吗
Lucia: 也行我先给他们拿过去吧
Tasha: 哎这还有个孜然
Tasha: 这什么东西啊芝麻
Lucia: 芝麻哎呀
Lucia: Sesame, oh no!
Shure: 小心那个别碰着那铁子
Shure: Be careful, don't touch that metal thing.
Lucia: 拿过去吧
Lucia: Take it over there.
Lucia: 看能不能用着
Lucia: See if we can use it.
Tasha: 这个地方等会要放蛋糕
Tasha: We'll put the cake here later.
Shure: 真能吃咱先偷偷造一个来来来
Shure: If you can really eat, let's secretly make one first. Come on, come on.
Tasha: 你旁边那个架子
Tasha: The shelf next to you.
Lucia: 有什么新的进展吗
Lucia: Any new developments?
Lucia: 这个辣椒面和那个芝麻
Lucia: This chili powder and sesame seeds.
Lucia: 如果需要撒的话
Lucia: If you need to sprinkle them.
Lucia: 啊他不是有那个影影
Lucia: Oh, doesn't he have that shadow...
Tasha: 给你讲个恐怖故事
Tasha: Let me tell you a scary story.
Lucia: 影楼影城
Lucia: Shadow studio, shadow city.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不是影楼影棚灯吗
Lucia: Aren't they shadow studio lights?
Tasha: 我哥他以前就是切西瓜
Tasha: My brother used to cut watermelons.
Tasha: 然后西瓜跟着走了
Tasha: And the watermelon moved.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 他的手也跟着走
Tasha: His hand moved with it.
Tasha: 然后他把他的手砍下来了
Tasha: Then he cut off his hand.
Lucia: 从里边拉个插板过来
Lucia: Pull an extension cord from inside.
Jake:啊为什么
Jake: Why?
Lucia: 但是拉板不是插板可能
Lucia: But it might not be an extension cord.
Tasha: 就是他想砍西瓜的时候
Tasha: It's when he wanted to cut the watermelon.
Lucia: 没那么长
Lucia: It's not that long.
Tasha: 然后西瓜滚了一点
Tasha: Then the watermelon rolled a bit.
Tasha: 然后他的手也跟着滚了一点
Tasha: And his hand rolled a bit too.
Lucia: 我看看啊
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:然后呢手没了
Jake: And then his hand was gone.
Tasha: 手就切下来了
Tasha: His hand got cut off.
Jake:就切下来了
Jake: It got cut off.
Lucia: 这地方这地方的店算了
Lucia: This place, this place's store, forget it.
Jake:就整个手嘛
Jake: The whole hand, right?
Tasha: 后来又用什么线切回去
Tasha: Later they used some thread to sew it back.
Tasha: 所以我对于切这个东西很很恐惧
Tasha: So I'm really scared of cutting stuff.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Jake:确实有用吗
Jake: Did it actually work?
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It worked.
Jake:这个接回去
Jake: They reattached it?
Lucia: 烧烤组说能整个灯不
Lucia: The BBQ team asked if they could get a lamp.
Tasha: 烧烤组
Tasha: The BBQ team?
Lucia: 因为外面有点暗
Lucia: Because it's a bit dark outside.
Lucia: 他们现在就是在打着手电筒看
Lucia: They're using flashlights to see right now.
Lucia: 那个就是烤箱里面的
Lucia: Inside the oven.
Lucia: 不是烤箱烤炉里面的情况
Lucia: Not the oven, the grill.
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think.
Lucia: 但是我感觉
Lucia: But I feel like
Lucia: 咱们这个插对一个插板也不够长
Lucia: even if we had an extension cord, it wouldn't be long enough.
Jake:电线弄不出去
Jake: The wire can't reach out.
Lucia: 哪怕真有一个空了的话
Lucia: Even if there is an empty one.
Jake:没电
Jake: No power.
Tasha: 那个支架
Tasha: That stand,
Tasha: 能不能把手电筒放上面会不会好点
Tasha: can we put the flashlight on it? Would that be better?
Tasha: 就不用举着了
Tasha: So we don't have to hold it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 把那个手机固定到云台或者什么上面
Lucia: Fix the phone on a gimbal or something.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 有有有有手机夹子或者啥的
Lucia: There's something here that looks like it can hold a phone.
Lucia: 这有个看起来有点像能夹手机的东西
Lucia: This looks like it can hold a phone.
Jake:可以啊那我就觉得呢
Jake: Alright, I think so.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 但我不太确定它具体是个啥这个
Lucia: But I'm not really sure what exactly it is.
Tasha: 没关系哈哈
Tasha: It's okay, haha.
Jake:我在想想
Jake: Let me think about it.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Jake:哈哈哈手机
Jake: Hahaha, the phone.
Lucia: 哈哈哈震动模式结束了
Lucia: Hahaha, the vibration mode is over.
Jake:哈哈关机了
Jake: Hahaha, it turned off.
Lucia: 震动模式关机了
Lucia: The vibration mode turned off.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你关机没电了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, you turned it off because it's out of battery, right?
Lucia: 这东西是干嘛的
Lucia: What's this thing for?
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right, yeah.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 这个是这里
Lucia: This is for...
Lucia: 这是您之前用来想用来固定go Pro的吗
Lucia: Is this what you used before to fix the GoPro?
Lucia: 还是干嘛
Lucia: Or what?
Jake:对是是这么回事
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:但是固定手机确实不太合适
Jake: But it's not really suitable for fixing a phone.
Lucia: 哦对手机带有一个那样
Lucia: Oh right, the phone has one of those.
Lucia: 就是跟自拍杆一样那种纸
Lucia: Like a selfie stick clamp.
Jake:对加起来对
Jake: Yeah, put it together, right.
Lucia: 那种夹子才行
Lucia: That kind of clamp would work.
Lucia: 这他用这边把手机夹坏了
Lucia: Otherwise, this will damage the phone.
Lucia: 那咋整啊
Lucia: What should we do?
Lucia: 整个绳给他绑到上面吧
Lucia: Let's just tie it up with a string.
Jake:我我也来取材一下
Jake: I'll also get some materials.
Jake:考察一下
Jake: Do some research.
Jake:外边没有电哈
Jake: There's no power outside.
Alice:老板要不要尝一个
Alice: Boss, do you want to try one?
Jake:啊好了
Jake: Ah, alright.
Shure: 好了好了
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 快快快叫出来叫出来快快快
Shure: Hurry up, call it out, call it out, quick, quick, quick.
Alice:哎呦呦我去
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:我去怎么吃
Jake: How do I eat this?
Jake:这个真
Jake: This really...
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What?
Jake:这边真的没电吗
Jake: Is there really no power here?
Alice:你你把你把芝麻给我呗
Alice: Can you give me the sesame seeds?
Shure: 撒点芝麻是吗
Shure: Sprinkle some sesame seeds, right?
Alice:芝麻跟辣椒面自己撒吧
Alice: Sprinkle the sesame and chili powder yourself.
Shure: 这个很咸
Shure: This is really salty.
Alice:这个已经很咸了
Alice: This is already very salty.
Alice:你不管了
Alice: Don't worry about it.
Jake:哎这不是插座吗
Jake: Hey, isn't this a socket?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh, damn.
Jake:这不是插座吗卧槽
Jake: Isn't this a socket, damn.
Shure: 我操快快快
Shure: Oh shit, quick, quick, quick.
Alice:拿出来一个
Alice: Take one out.
Shure: 拿出来一个
Shure: Take one out.
Shure: 我快快瞎了都
Shure: I'm almost blind here.
Jake:外边有插座
Jake: There's a socket outside.
Jake:整半天外边有插座
Jake: We've been fussing around, and there's a socket outside.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 哦外面有插座
Lucia: Oh, there's a socket outside.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 我操有灯了有灯了
Shure: Oh shit, there's light, there's light.
Jake:哎还得是得彩排一次
Jake: Hey, we need to rehearse once.
Shure: 对所有的都得彩排
Shure: Yeah, everything needs a rehearsal.
Shure: 不然话到时候啥都
Shure: Otherwise, at the time, nothing will...
Jake:对你们表演一般怎么个彩排法
Jake: Yeah, how do you guys usually rehearse your performances?
Jake:不用彩排
Jake: No need to rehearse.
Jake:试一试一次拿倒
Jake: Just try it once and it's done.
Shure: 对就是对
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Shure: 挑两手试一下
Shure: Just try a couple of times.
Shure: 就把那个音色都调对了就OK
Shure: Adjust the tone, and it's all good.
Shure: 哎别别扣上他那挺埋汰的
Shure: Hey, don't put that cover on, it's dirty.
Shure: 那盖是脏的
Shure: That cover is filthy.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 加点大自然的味道
Shure: Add a bit of the natural flavor.
Alice:再能俩近点吗
Alice: Can you get a bit closer?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 应该撩不着
Shure: It shouldn't be a problem.
Shure: 太牛逼了
Shure: This is awesome.
Shure: 这头让他抬抬
Shure: Lift this up a bit.
Jake:我靠确实牛逼
Jake: Wow, this is really impressive.
Jake:就拿石头买卖
Jake: Just using stones.
Jake:确实牛逼
Jake: Really impressive.
Jake:这光一打确实牛逼的多
Jake: The light really makes it much better.
Jake:来师傅
Jake: Come on, master.
Alice:干嘛
Jake:两位师傅来
Jake: The two masters are here.
Shure: 一人一人摆拍一下先
Shure: Let's take turns posing for photos first.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Jake:摆拍摆拍
Jake: Pose, pose.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:挺厉害
Jake: Impressive.
Shure: 来吃饭好了
Shure: Let's eat.
Jake:来 2号师傅
Jake: Come on, Master #2.
Jake:你给他摆一摆
Jake: You pose for him.
Shure: 快来吃饭喽
Shure: Hurry up and eat.
Alice:就熟了两块水咋吃
Alice: How are we supposed to eat with just two cooked pieces?
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Eat, eat.
Shure: 凉了真凉了
Shure: It's really getting cold.
Jake:哈哈哈刚烤上
Jake: Haha, just grilled it.
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Eat, eat.
Jake:刚烤上一分钟就凉了
Jake: Just grilled it a minute ago, and it's already cold.
Shure: 快快快不然话凉了凉了真凉了
Shure: Hurry, hurry, otherwise it'll get cold, really cold.
Jake:完了完了
Jake: It's done, it's done.
Shure: 必须得整瓶啤啤
Shure: You gotta have a whole bottle of beer.
Shure: 你们赶紧拿两个筷子快吃
Shure: You guys quickly grab some chopsticks and eat.
Jake:哎来拿一串
Jake: Hey, come and get a skewer.
Shure: 就是再拿一个小刀什么的吧
Shure: Maybe get another knife or something.
Shure: 因为这个牌好像不是能一人一个的
Shure: Because it seems like this plate isn't enough for everyone.
Shure: 正好那个
Shure: Just right.
Jake:哦哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:就总共三个是吧
Jake: So, there are only three in total?
Shure: 一二现在这顶上几个
Shure: One, two, how many are on top now?
Jake:是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Jake:这这这有你啊
Jake: This, this, this is you, huh?
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:你你你看看吧我咱整不明白这啥
Jake: Look, I can't figure out what this is.
Lucia: 我这外面确实挺冷的
Lucia: It's really cold outside.
Shure: 卧槽这可以
Shure: Wow, this is cool.
Lucia: 烤串得赶快吃
Lucia: You gotta eat the skewers quickly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mhm.
Lucia: 大家这么谦让我就先吃了
Lucia: Since everyone's being so polite, I'll go ahead and eat.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我去哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm going, haha.
Lucia: 啊那走
Lucia: Ah, let's go.
Lucia: 我们再搬几个筷子出来
Lucia: Let's bring out a few more pairs of chopsticks.
Shure: 都可以了
Shure: That should be fine.
Alice:这两样可以
Alice: These two should be okay.
Jake:好咱咱咱确实要整点刀
Jake: Alright, we do need to get some knives.
Lucia: 问题是现在这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: The problem is, we don't have any other knives right now.
Lucia: 这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: We don't have any other knives.
Lucia: 不是这也没别的筷子
Lucia: No, we don't have any other chopsticks either.
Jake:啊筷子也没了
Jake: Ah, we're out of chopsticks too.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Jake:小刀没有小刀
Jake: No small knives, no small knives.
Shure: 小刀对能切羊排的餐刀
Shure: Small knives, yeah, like table knives for cutting lamb chops.
Katrina: 啊那你现在机事复习到哪一步了
Katrina: So, how far along are you with your machine studies?
Shure: 最好是餐刀
Shure: Ideally, table knives.
Shure: 不要不行不行
Shure: No, that won't work.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:吃
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake:我先把刀送过去
Jake: I'll take the knives over first.
Jake:没有小刀
Jake: No small knives.
Jake:你你给我个镜头
Jake: Can you give me a shot?
Shure: 啊哈哈哈哈
Shure: Ah, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:我来切了
Jake: I'll cut it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:这都会掉不回
Alice: This won't fall back.
Jake:好我拿点刀下来
Jake: Alright, I'll bring some knives down.
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Are there any other kitchen knives?
Shure: 快快快帮他下
Shure: Quick, quick, help him out.
Shure: 快帮他下
Shure: Quick, help him out.
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Are there any other kitchen knives?
Jake:就一个菜刀吗
Jake: Is there only one kitchen knife?
Shure: 哎都是菜刀能算啊
Shure: Yeah, it's all kitchen knives, does it count?
Shure: 那有剪子
Shure: There's a pair of scissors.
Shure: 那剪子是可以剪肉
Shure: Those scissors can cut meat.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 最后还是不行
Shure: In the end, it's still not working.
Shure: 还是得用上这
Shure: We still need to use this.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Shure: 个拿那个不是烤那个肉嘛
Shure: Isn't that for grilling the meat?
Alice:往这边转一点点
Alice: Turn it a little bit this way.
Jake:鸡翅烤哦还得用这个
Jake: Oh, you need this for grilling the chicken wings.
Shure: 然后那个拿拿一个那个卫生的那个
Shure: Then get one of those sanitary wipes.
Shure: 湿巾湿巾湿巾就在那
Shure: Wet wipes, wet wipes, they're right there.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 外面放了6双
Lucia: There are 6 pairs outside.
Lucia: 这几双筷子先放这
Lucia: Let's just put these chopsticks here.
Lucia: 呃放放这吧
Lucia: Um, just put them here.
Lucia: 一会要是需要用再拿
Lucia: We'll grab them if we need them later.
Lucia: 嗯我刚才吃的
Lucia: Hmm, I just ate.
Tasha: 哇切的好平整呀
Tasha: Wow, you cut it so neatly.
Jake:哎呀好烫
Jake: Ouch, it's so hot.
Jake:真的好烫
Jake: It's really hot.
Tasha: 烫
Tasha: Hot.
Katrina: 然后你就
Katrina: And then you...
Jake:是挺烫
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty hot.
Jake:确实
Jake: Definitely.
Jake:还能补救吗
Jake: Can it be salvaged?
Tasha: 没办法没关系
Tasha: No way, it's fine.
Jake:碘伏准备哎
Jake: Get the iodine ready.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:对不起了碘伏
Jake: Sorry, iodine.
Jake:用不上你了
Jake: We won't need you.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:这是个锅底
Jake: This is a pot base.
Lucia: 我不知道这一层这一层要干嘛呀
Lucia: I don't know what this layer is for.
Jake:这是个锅底是吧
Jake: This is a pot base, right?
Jake:尝尝吧啊不是
Jake: Try it, oh no.
Katrina: 做到哪一步了
Katrina: What step are we on?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 谢谢好吧
Lucia: Thanks, alright.
Jake:那我们就扒了吃了吧
Jake: Let's just peel it and eat it.
Lucia: 那我们就扒了吃了吧挺好吃吃了
Lucia: Let's just peel it and eat it. It's quite tasty.
Jake:挺好吃挺好吃
Jake: It's really good.
Jake:吃了哈哈
Jake: Let's eat, haha.
Tasha: 糖醋伯爵
Tasha: Sweet and sour Earl.
Lucia: 嗯真好好吃
Lucia: Hmm, it's really delicious.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:好两两两
Jake: Okay, two, two, two.
Jake:哎三三也行
Jake: Hey, three, three is fine too.
Jake:我试试我来测一测
Jake: Let me try, I'll measure it.
Jake:放心放心
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake:我测一测
Jake: I'll measure it.
Jake:我我测一测我测一测
Jake: I'll, I'll measure it, I'll measure it.
Jake:哎哎哎好好好
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 您测您测
Tasha: You measure, you measure.
Jake:我先测一测
Jake: I'll measure it first.
Tasha: 好您测
Tasha: Okay, you measure.
Lucia: 你搓的时候把这底下再吃点
Lucia: When you're rubbing it, eat a bit from the bottom.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不着急不着急
Lucia: Hahaha, no rush, no rush.
Jake:哈哈哈那我慢慢测哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, then I'll measure slowly, hahaha.
Tasha: 2层咱们就加入芒果
Tasha: For the second layer, we'll add mango.
Jake:这两层嘛
Jake: These two layers, right?
Jake:这三层嘛
Jake: These three layers, right?
Tasha: 好那你就切三层
Tasha: Okay, then you cut three layers.
Jake:我我再试一下
Jake: I'll, I'll try again.
Lucia: 不是你切着切着咱们把这吃完了
Lucia: If you keep cutting, we'll finish eating this.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 开始了吗杨老师
Tasha: Have you started, Mr. Yang?
Jake:开始开始开始开始开始
Jake: Start, start, start, start, start.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey, hey.
Tasha: 哎哎你放的太窄了
Tasha: Hey, hey, you're placing it too narrow.
Lucia: 你放的太窄了
Lucia: You're placing it too narrow.
Tasha: 一人干活两人帮协助
Tasha: One person works, two people assist.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful.
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Watch your hand.
Katrina: 这是在做什么
Katrina: What are we doing?
Jake:再切蛋糕再分层
Jake: Cutting the cake, making layers.
Shure: 还没有
Shure: Not yet.
Alice:再加一点
Alice: Add a bit more.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay.
Jake:再来一层
Jake: One more layer.
Lucia: 这真的还够再切一层吗
Lucia: Is there really enough to cut another layer?
Tasha: 你看这一层多厚啊
Tasha: Look how thick this layer is.
Lucia: 再再切太薄了
Lucia: Cutting it again will make it too thin.
Lucia: 别别别又给最后
Lucia: No, no, no, not again at the end.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 我们做出来一个pancake是吧哈哈
Lucia: We made a pancake, right? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure.
Tasha: 哈可以吗
Tasha: Haha, is it okay?
Jake:吗可以
Jake: Is it okay?
Jake:好可以吧
Jake: Alright, it should be fine.
Lucia: 杨老板这么自信肯定能签好
Lucia: Jake is so confident, it must be good.
Jake:姚老板这么自信肯定能切好
Jake:等一下我再测一下
Jake: Wait a moment, let me check again.
Jake:这可以吧
Jake: This should be okay, right?
Lucia: 我不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你看你得问
Lucia: You see, you have to ask.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 你过来
Tasha: Come over here.
Jake:我怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Tasha: 你看这个怎么了
Tasha: Look at this, what's wrong with it?
Jake:啊我我的几号
Jake: Ah, which one is mine?
Jake:我的4号
Jake: Mine is number 4.
Lucia: 你的最后最边角的这个怎么就这么点
Lucia: Why is your last corner piece so small?
Lucia: 不是你不是再分配过了吗
Lucia: Didn't you redistribute it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈这也太离谱了吧
Lucia: Haha, this is so ridiculous.
Jake:不是不是客观
Jake: No, no, it's objective.
Jake:不是客观规律吗
Jake: It's not an objective rule?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈这叉子
Lucia: Hahahahaha, this fork.
Lucia: 哎呀你看这个好多呀
Lucia: Oh my, look at this, there’s so much.
Lucia: 哎这个怎么这么过分
Lucia: Oh, this is so unfair.
Lucia: 没事没事这个预期效果和实际
Lucia: It's okay, the expected result and the actual...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你这已经切开了一部分了好吗
Lucia: You've already cut some of it, okay?
Jake:哈哈哈剪刀在这个左边
Jake: Hahaha, the scissors are on the left side.
Jake:水水是左边
Jake: The water is on the left side.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 不是你底下那点切开了一些了
Lucia: Didn't you cut a bit from the bottom already?
Lucia: 在他那里面随便加点啥他就两种风味
Lucia: Just add a little bit of anything in there and it has two flavors.
Lucia: 一半是不是我瞎说的你干嘛
Lucia: Half of it is just me talking nonsense, what are you doing?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Jake:哈我觉得合理
Jake: Ha, I think it makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个
Lucia: Wow, this
Lucia: 擦干了是吧
Lucia: Is it dry now?
Lucia: 我再摸摸
Lucia: Let me touch it again.
Lucia: 我我反正我刚擦
Lucia: I just wiped it.
Lucia: 我觉得是干了
Lucia: I think it's dry.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 干了我还不在行行行
Lucia: It's dry, I wasn't sure.
Jake:杨森我又来了
Jake: Yang Sen, I'm back again.
Lucia: 我觉得你有喜欢
Lucia: I think you like it.
Lucia: 偷偷用嘴
Lucia: Secretly using your mouth.
Lucia: 哈哈没事没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 两层奶油的话是用多少
Lucia: How much for two layers of cream?
Lucia: 这个呀
Lucia: This one?
Tasha: 你倒倒倒2
Tasha: You pour, pour, pour...
Tasha: 嗯好你把糖吧倒糖这边嗯
Tasha: Mm, okay, you pour the sugar here, mm.
Lucia: 哇正好
Lucia: Wow, perfect.
Lucia: 200克天才
Lucia: 200 grams, genius.
Lucia: 天才是怎样炼成的
Lucia: How a genius is made.
Jake:我还可以切一层你信不信
Jake: I can still cut another layer, believe it or not.
Jake:我觉得我切嗨了
Jake: I think I'm on a roll with cutting.
Lucia: 真的不需要看着他点吗
Lucia: Do you really not need to watch it?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哎加加20克糖
Tasha: Hey, add 20 grams of sugar.
Jake:我觉得我势不可挡啊
Jake: I feel unstoppable.
Lucia: 此处应该有BGM
Lucia: There should be some BGM here.
Lucia: 我这是不是要清零一下啊
Lucia: Should I reset this?
Lucia: 吧
Lucia: Right?
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Jake:你到底切了多少层 4层
Jake: How many layers did you cut in the end? Four layers?
Jake:怎么样好
Jake: How is it, good?
小薇 ：那你去把芒果切一下吧
Tasha: Then go cut the mango.
Jake:切给我好的
Jake: Cut it for me, alright.
Tasha: 我刚想说少一克
Tasha: I was just about to say it's one gram less.
Tasha: 我们主打一个低糖
Tasha: We're aiming for low sugar.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a minute.
Lucia: 这这这这这啥情况
Lucia: This, this, this, what's going on?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是另外一个他好像安的时候
Lucia: But the other one, when he was installing it,
Lucia: 还没有擦干哦
Lucia: it wasn't dry yet.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 我还以为放那控就可以控干再擦一遍
Lucia: I thought if we left it there to drain, it would dry and then we could wipe it again.
Lucia: 哎只能呕在这
Lucia: Ah, we can only do this.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Lucia: 他们外面是不是可以了呀
Lucia: Are they done outside?
Tasha: 这好聪明啊
Tasha: This is so smart.
Tasha: 这是谁想出来的想法
Tasha: Whose idea was this?
Tasha: 这样就可以了
Tasha: This works.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 下面能吃了吗
Lucia: Can we eat what's below?
Lucia: 啊太好了
Lucia: Ah, great.
Lucia: 我先把这个这个给安上
Lucia: Let me install this first.
Jake:我也要吃嗯
Jake: I want to eat too, hmm.
Katrina: 一人一个腿呀
Katrina: One leg each.
Jake:还有吗还有吗还有吗还有吗
Jake: Is there more? Is there more? Is there more?
Lucia: 好的这个你看他就是会那个啥
Lucia: Okay, look at this, it will do that thing.
Jake:拿个小的
Jake: Take a small one.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Hmm, hmm.
Jake:哦这个可以吧
Jake: Oh, this one is fine, right?
Jake:一般是多大
Jake: What's the usual size?
Shure: 一般是多大
Shure: What's the usual size?
Shure: 都可以都可以吃吧
Shure: Anything is fine to eat.
Jake:行行行试试
Jake: Okay, okay, let's try.
Shure: 本来反正就没有
Shure: Anyway, we don't have...
Shure: 主厨主厨吃到了就行
Shure: As long as the chef gets to eat, it's fine.
Jake:谁管奶不都奶子吗
Jake: Who cares, it's all the same milk, right?
Jake:吃肉了吗
Jake: Did you eat the meat?
Jake:吃肉啊吃了
Jake: Eat the meat, yes.
Shure: 配着绝逼牛逼
Shure: Paired with this, it's absolutely awesome.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Jake:干羊排
Jake: Dry lamb ribs.
Shure: 那羊排谁没吃着
Shure: Who didn't get the lamb ribs?
Shure: 然后把那一块都吃了吧
Shure: Then let's eat that piece too.
Katrina: 真没吃
Katrina: Really didn't eat.
Shure: 来录录一个开香槟
Shure: Come on, record popping the champagne.
Jake:我再拿个灯下来吧
Jake: I'll bring another light down.
Jake:我这边也打掉
Jake: I'll take care of this side too.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Mm, okay.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm.
Shure: 而且这个室室外这圈灯不亮了
Shure: Also, the lights outside in this area aren't working.
Shure: 你没发现吗
Shure: Didn't you notice?
Jake:哎为啥呀
Jake: Hey, why is that?
Jake:灯被我抢了
Jake: I took the light.
Katrina: 拍高一点
Katrina: Take a higher shot.
Jake:呃我看看哈
Jake: Uh, let me see.
Jake:嗯应该可能大概
Jake: Hmm, it should probably be okay.
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:哎好了好了
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Jake:去是的是是的
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:是这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
Tasha: 有两个插座吗
Tasha: Are there two sockets?
Jake:嗯有插
Jake: Yeah, there's a socket.
Jake:插线板对
Jake: A power strip, right.
Jake:有插有有有拖过去
Jake: There's a socket, yes, yes, yes, drag it over.
Jake:给你打个灯
Jake: Let me get you a light.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Jake:慢点慢点慢点
Jake: Slowly, slowly, slowly.
Shure: 慢点慢点慢
Shure: Slowly, slowly, slow.
Jake:给你打灯给你打灯
Jake: Let me get you a light, let me get you a light.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, you're killing me.
Katrina: 你是某个那种晚会的
Katrina: Are you from some kind of show?
Jake:瓶下留人
Jake: Hold on.
Alice:有点干巴
Alice: It's a bit dry.
Alice:有没有那种油比较多的肉啊
Alice: Do you have any meat with more fat?
Jake:跟火一样打不着
Jake: It's like trying to light a fire.
Shure: 我就不信你今天靠气唇开不开
Shure: I don't believe you can't open it today.
Shure: 他奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Jake:是不是39
Jake: Is it 39?
Jake:块钱的就不行了
Jake: The 39 yuan one doesn't work?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 没开过 39块钱的呀
Shure: Never opened a 39 yuan one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他妈啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40呢
Shure: Damn, a beer usually costs 40 for just one cup.
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Okay, that's enough.
Shure: 这回准备
Shure: Let's get ready.
Shure: 321
Shure: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 虽然很不优雅
Shure: Even though it's not very elegant,
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:但是很成功
Jake: But it was successful.
Katrina: 去换他一下吧
Katrina: Let's go and change it.
Katrina: 感觉他一直靠我来考吧
Katrina: I feel like he's always relying on me to take the test.
Katrina: 就是翻一下就行是吧
Katrina: Just flip it over, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:对这是大徒弟和哈哈
Jake: Yes, this is the big apprentice and haha.
Jake:我继续切继续切
Jake: I'll keep chopping, keep chopping.
Jake:好我来了
Jake: Alright, I'm here.
Jake:看完香槟干劲十足
Jake: After watching the champagne, I'm full of energy.
Lucia: 大概要打成什么样呀
Lucia: How should I beat this?
Tasha: 呃固体状就行了
Tasha: Make it solid.
Tasha: 这样是肯定不行的
Tasha: This way won't work.
Lucia: 固体状对
Lucia: Solid, right.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 一共是7个人是吧
Tasha: There are 7 people in total, right?
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 那就写7个桶
Tasha: Then write 7 buckets.
Jake:为什么是7个人
Jake: Why are there 7 people?
Jake:那是几个人哦
Jake: How many people are there?
Katrina: 首先炒一会看看蛋还行
Katrina: First, stir-fry a bit and see if the eggs are okay.
Jake:6个人
Jake: 6 people.
Jake:可以是7个人一会一会会来一个人
Jake:但是他不一定什么时候来
Jake: But he might not come at all.
Jake:哎垃圾桶没了
Jake: Oh, the trash can is gone.
Jake:啊垃圾桶没了
Jake: Ah, the trash can is gone.
Lucia: 要不要再再再打一下
Lucia: Should I beat it again?
Jake:垃圾桶没了
Jake: The trash can is gone.
Jake:我们暂且
Jake: Let's just...
Alice:筷子给我
Alice: Give me the chopsticks.
Jake:谢谢你哇
Jake: Thank you so much.
Tasha: 就这样的
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 洗手我也这样洗啊
Tasha: This is how I wash my hands too.
Lucia: 现在呢我感觉好像
Lucia: Now I feel like...
Jake:不应该吗
Jake: Isn't that right?
Lucia: 对你看一眼
Lucia: Yeah, take a look.
Lucia: 然后把
Lucia: And then put
Lucia: 用刮刀把它刮到那个裱花嘴里面
Lucia: Use a spatula to scrape it into the piping bag.
Shure: 终于明白人类为什么发明蓝牙了
Shure: Finally, I understand why humans invented Bluetooth.
Lucia: 好的剩下这个
Lucia: Okay, this one left
Lucia: 这盘是干净的吧
Lucia: This plate is clean, right?
Lucia: 那我先在这放一下
Lucia: I'll put it here for now.
Tasha: 如果你有4只手的话会不会变成猴子
Tasha: If you had four hands, would you turn into a monkey?
Lucia: 那个刮刀在哪里
Lucia: Where is that spatula?
Lucia: 是不是在这边呀
Lucia: Is it over here?
Lucia: 刮刀嗯刮刀刮刀刮刀
Lucia: Spatula, spatula, spatula...
Lucia: 哈哈哈竟然在这里
Lucia: Hahaha, it's actually here.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我要把它放到
Lucia: I'm going to put it
Lucia: 放到哪也要把它洗干净擦干
Lucia: Wherever, but it needs to be washed and dried.
Lucia: 嗯然后然后放到裱花袋里呃
Lucia: Hmm, then put it in the piping bag, uh...
Shure: 太他妈艰苦了
Shure: This is so damn hard.
Lucia: 可以那但是就是那
Lucia: It's okay, but still
Lucia: 需要一个人撑一下这个小花袋
Lucia: We need someone to hold this small piping bag.
Tasha: OK我来了
Tasha: OK, I'm here.
Tasha: 我把草莓扒完
Tasha: Let me finish peeling the strawberries.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:对啊那个裱花嘴呢
Jake: Yeah, where's that piping tip?
Tasha: 裱花嘴你到底洗到哪里
Tasha: Where did you end up washing the piping tip?
Jake:我应该放在某一个容器里爆
Jake: I think I put it in some container, maybe.
Lucia: 没事至少我们还有裱花袋
Lucia: No worries, at least we still have the piping bag.
Lucia: 有吧哦在这
Lucia: Right? Oh, here it is.
Lucia: 别我刚话音话音未落
Lucia: Wait, just as I was saying...
Lucia: 他发现他还找不着
Lucia: He found out he still couldn't find it.
Lucia: 那就比较搞笑了
Lucia: That would be funny.
Lucia: 对对对这里
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, here it is.
Lucia: 咱们的剪刀首先它不知道在哪里
Lucia: First of all, our scissors are nowhere to be found.
Lucia: 其次它好像是用来剪快递的哈哈哈
Lucia: Secondly, they seem to be used for cutting packages, hahaha.
Jake:嗯外边有剪刀
Jake: Hmm, there's scissors outside.
Lucia: 外面有剪刀
Lucia: There's scissors outside.
Jake:外边是切肉的
Jake: The ones outside are for cutting meat.
Lucia: 外面那个已经剪肉了
Lucia: The ones outside have been used to cut meat.
Jake:嗯肉也
Jake: Hmm, meat too.
Lucia: 嗯疯了能用
Lucia: Hmm, crazy, but usable.
Jake:那切一下
Jake: Then let's cut it.
Lucia: 切不开我来切
Lucia: If you can't cut it, I'll do it.
Jake:我来切我来切
Jake: I'll cut it, I'll cut it.
Lucia: 让对让我来切
Lucia: No, let me cut it.
Lucia: 牛啊我可以来
Lucia: Wow, I can do it.
Jake:我可以来
Jake: I can do it.
Jake:去哪去这去这
Jake: Where to? Here? Here?
Lucia: 切了
Lucia: Cut it.
Tasha: 牛啊哇啊
Tasha: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 牛啊哇
Lucia: Amazing, wow.
Jake:我还没用尽呢哎
Jake: I haven't used all my strength yet.
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia: 怎么
Lucia: How?
Jake:没我刚刚还
Jake: No, I just...
Jake:我刚刚还没用尽呢
Jake: I haven't used all my strength yet.
Jake:怎么就开了
Jake: How did it open?
Tasha: 不愧是一代高臣
Tasha: Truly worthy of a great minister.
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia: 转世
Lucia: Reincarnated.
Jake:厨神转世
Jake: Reincarnated chef.
Lucia: 重生之我是小富贵呃哈哈
Lucia: Reborn as a little rich kid, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:能不能说点好的哈哈
Jake: Can you say something nicer, haha.
Lucia: 我再想想
Lucia: I'll think about it.
Lucia: 重生之我是米其林主厨
Lucia: Reborn as a Michelin chef.
Jake:好这个可以
Jake: Okay, that's good.
Lucia: 怎么小福贵
Lucia: What, little rich kid?
Lucia: 你不愿意
Lucia: You don't like it?
Jake:呃好吧
Jake: Uh, alright.
Lucia: 里面的这个茶给人一种香草籽的感觉
Lucia: The tea inside gives a vanilla seed feeling.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 天然香草的话就会有香草籽
Lucia: If it's natural vanilla, it will have vanilla seeds.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:第3个Mango
Jake: The third one, Mango.
Lucia: 不错转化率怎么样
Lucia: Not bad, how's the conversion rate?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没有我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: Hahaha, just kidding.
Jake:哈哈哈可以称一称
Jake: Hahaha, we can weigh it.
Jake:来称称一称吧
Jake: Let's weigh it.
Jake:称一称称一称称一称
Jake: Weigh it, weigh it, weigh it.
Jake:有称吗在用是吧
Jake: Do we have a scale? Is it in use?
Jake:有称没有在用
Jake: Do we have a scale or not?
Jake:来来来不是可以
Jake: Come on, come on, it's okay.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 转化率怎么样了
Lucia: How's the conversion rate?
Lucia: 哈哈我看看
Lucia: Haha, let me see.
Jake:我们看看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Tasha: 那个盒子制作的话是400克还是500克的
Tasha: Is that box made of 400 grams or 500 grams?
Shure: 来来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 这这上面还有草莓
Lucia: This, this still has strawberries on it.
Jake:草莓没有
Jake: No strawberries.
Lucia: 草莓还有糖怎么办
Lucia: What about the strawberries and sugar?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:我们一会加上去
Jake: We'll add them later.
Lucia: 好开始
Lucia: Alright, start.
Tasha: 这是一个92克的芒果好行
Tasha: This is a 92-gram mango, okay.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:先就放这吧
Jake: Just put it here first.
Lucia: 就放这吧
Lucia: Just put it here.
Jake:好吧行
Jake: Okay, fine.
Lucia: 好行放
Lucia: Okay, put it down.
Tasha: 放这再切一个就行了
Tasha: Put it here and cut another one.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:一个92克的芒果
Jake: A 92-gram mango.
Lucia: 这剩下的芒果可以吃了对吧哈哈哈
Lucia: We can eat the leftover mango, right? Hahaha.
Lucia: 蹑手蹑脚的靠近
Lucia: Sneaking closer.
Jake:好有两个好的
Jake: Alright, two good ones.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:这什么呀蚝油
Jake: What is this, oyster sauce?
Lucia: 哇越发熟练了
Lucia: Wow, getting more skilled.
Lucia: 不错熟能生巧啊
Lucia: Not bad, practice makes perfect.
Tasha: 熟能生巧啊
Tasha: Practice makes perfect.
Lucia: 你看他夸一夸
Lucia: Look at him, praising.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我之前记得那个什么
Lucia: Hahaha, I remember that...
Jake:哈哈哈马上菜刀就掉了
Jake: Hahaha, the knife is about to fall.
Tasha: 只要一群女生围在他旁边夸他
Tasha: As long as there's a group of girls praising him.
Tasha: 他就会啊哈哈
Tasha: He will... haha.
Jake:我就会什么他就会怎么
Jake: What will I do? What will he do?
Lucia: 哈这什么原话
Lucia: Huh, what was the exact phrase?
Jake:菜刀就会掉了
Jake: The knife will fall.
Lucia: 王者我也不记得反正就这个意思
Lucia: I don't remember exactly, but that was the gist.
Jake:哈哈哈好厉害啊
Jake: Hahaha, so impressive.
Tasha: 好厉害啊
Tasha: Wow, that's amazing!
Tasha: 衣服好好看呀
Tasha: The clothes look so nice.
Tasha: 店里面衣服怎么这么好看
Tasha: How come the clothes in the store are so good-looking?
Lucia: 能便宜点吗
Lucia: Can it be cheaper?
Jake:能便宜点吗
Jake: Can it be cheaper?
Lucia: 再便宜点
Lucia: Even cheaper.
Jake:能便宜点
Jake: Can it be cheaper?
Lucia: 对我好像我好像
Lucia: I think I...
Jake:我好像朋友圈都送了
Jake: I think I posted it on my moments.
Lucia: 我好像刷到过这个类似的梗
Lucia: I think I've seen a similar joke.
Jake:考完了
Jake: Finished the exam.
Shure: 没有没有了哈哈哈
Shure: No, it's not over, haha.
Jake:什么什么叫没有了
Jake: What do you mean it's not over?
Lucia: 什么没有了
Lucia: What do you mean it's not over?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:什么叫没有了考完了
Jake: What do you mean it's not over? The exam's done.
Shure: 也不是
Shure: Not really.
Shure: 我拿啥呢
Shure: What am I holding?
Shure: 那个烧烤料对
Shure: That BBQ seasoning, right.
Lucia: 嗯我拿了那个辣椒粉和那个芝麻
Lucia: Hmm, I got the chili powder and the sesame seeds.
Shure: 有一个
Shure: There's one...
Lucia: 都在外面
Lucia: They're all outside.
Lucia: 你看还有啥别的
Lucia: See if there's anything else.
Shure: 有一个袋装的那个
Shure: There's one in a bag.
Katrina: 我想我和你之间的差距
Katrina: I think about the gap between you and me.
Lucia: 您的盘子已经准备好了
Lucia: Your plate is ready.
Jake:好的这是什么
Jake: Okay, what's this?
Jake:这是半年总结
Jake: This is the mid-year summary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 刚是多少来着
Lucia: What was the number again?
Jake:刚刚是多少单的那个数字 92
Jake: What was the number of orders again? 92.
Lucia: 92好像
Lucia: 92, I think.
Lucia: 不过考虑到皮和那个核
Lucia: But considering the skin and the core...
Lucia: 我们还可以有一些
Lucia: We can still have some...
Jake:不用考虑
Jake: No need to consider.
Lucia: 我们可以有一些depreciation了哈
Lucia: We can have some depreciation, right?
Jake:好哈哈哈自信一点
Jake: Okay, hahaha, be more confident.
Jake:不不要考虑
Jake: No, don't consider it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈就要8%
Jake: Hahaha, just need 8%.
Lucia: 哈不要考虑
Lucia: Ha, don't consider it.
Lucia: 你不是违背那个什么
Lucia: Aren't you violating that...
Lucia: 热力学第一定律了吗
Lucia: The first law of thermodynamics?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:牛顿要出来了是吧
Jake: Newton's coming out, right?
Lucia: 热力学第一定律是谁发现的
Lucia: Who discovered the first law of thermodynamics?
Jake:那是什么东西
Jake: What's that?
Jake:牛顿
Jake: Newton.
Lucia: 管他呢反正都是牛嘴
Lucia: Who cares, it's all Newton's stuff.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 他们外面好了吗
Lucia: Are they done outside?
Lucia: 好饿哦他们
Lucia: They're so hungry.
Jake:是啊好饿
Jake: Yeah, they're hungry.
Lucia: 让我再观摩一下这个
Lucia: Let me observe this for a bit.
Jake:我的4号
Jake: My number 4.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 你
Lucia: You.
Jake:4号小蛋糕
Jake: Number 4 little cake.
Lucia: 看他好可怜
Lucia: Look at it, it's so pitiful.
Jake:他好少啊
Jake: It's so little.
Tasha: 一开始就跟他说了
Tasha: I told him from the start.
Tasha: 杨老师不患寡而患不均哈哈哈
Tasha: Mr. Yang is not afraid of lack but of inequality, hahaha.
Jake:怎么办一会第一个吃他吧
Jake: What to do? Let's eat it first.
Jake:对他好一点
Jake: Be nicer to it.
Lucia: 怀疑你在阐述什么奇怪的定律
Lucia: I suspect you're explaining some weird law.
Lucia: 比如说马太效应什么的
Lucia: Like the Matthew effect or something.
Jake:哦是这个还行吧
Jake: Oh, is it? That should be okay.
Jake:看测一下
Jake: Let's measure it.
Lucia: 怎么测呢
Lucia: How do we measure it?
Lucia: 我们一看归零了啊哎
Lucia: We see it reset to zero, ah hey.
Tasha: 哦就这样就行了
Tasha: Oh, that's fine.
Tasha: 因为我们没有51
Tasha: Because we don't have 51.
Jake:哦过半了好好
Jake: Oh, it's past halfway, good.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 还不错
Lucia: Not bad.
Lucia: 因为本身这些核和皮就有一些
Lucia: Because these cores and skins themselves have some...
Jake:的
Jake: Right.
Jake:我现在在忙切
Jake: I'm busy cutting now.
Lucia: 嗯糖粉
Lucia: Hmm, powdered sugar.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎这个这个是
Lucia: Hey, this, this is...
Jake:去哪
Jake: Where are you going?
Lucia: 这俩是干净的吗
Lucia: Are these two clean?
Lucia: 要冲冲吗还是
Lucia: Do we need to rinse them or...
Lucia: 行反正好几天没用了
Lucia: It's fine, they haven't been used for days.
Shure: 我油还回来了吗
Shure: Has my oil been returned?
Katrina: 这已经差不多了
Katrina: This is almost done.
Shure: 没有是吗
Shure: No, right?
Shure: 油没还回来
Shure: The oil hasn't been returned.
Tasha: 就在那个商考架旁边
Tasha: It's right next to the shopping shelf.
Shure: 一张照片不太
Shure: One photo isn't quite...
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:我在干嘛
Jake: What am I doing?
Tasha: 你干嘛呢在偷吃是吧
Tasha: What are you doing? Are you sneaking a bite?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:我要把这一点对
Jake: I'm just trying to get this right.
Lucia: 他提高转化率
Lucia: He's trying to increase the conversion rate.
Jake:用一些用一些细枝末节的手段
Jake: Using some little tricks.
Jake:哈哈哈在哪
Jake: Haha, where?
Jake:嗯增加1.1%
Jake: Hmm, increase by 1.1%.
Lucia: 姚老师您切的
Lucia: Mr. Yao, your slicing is...
Lucia: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Lucia: Thin as a cicada's wing, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈这不是适合铺在上面吗
Jake: Haha, isn't it perfect for laying on top?
Lucia: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Lucia: Thin as a cicada's wing, haha.
Lucia: 来吧
Lucia: Come on.
Jake:好
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Lucia: 您就坐在这里
Lucia: You just sit here.
Jake:我坐在这里
Jake: I'll sit here.
Jake:你们也坐
Jake: You guys sit too.
Shure: 这边差不多
Shure: It's almost done here.
Jake:来我们一起坐
Jake: Come on, let's all sit.
Tasha: 怎么一起坐
Tasha: How do we all sit?
Jake:就哈哈确实
Jake: Just... haha, indeed.
Lucia: 只有两个凳子呢哈哈哈
Lucia: There are only two stools, haha.
Jake:那我先坐
Jake: Then I'll sit first.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Lucia: 两凳子都归你了
Lucia: Both chairs are yours now.
Jake:哈哈哈我分分
Jake: Hahaha, I'll share.
Shure: 然后给他们分一半出去好吧
Shure: Then give half of it to them, alright?
Lucia: 坐在飞机上占用边的座位
Lucia: Occupying the seats by the side on the plane.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah.
Jake:那我得躺着坐
Jake: Then I'll have to lie down to sit.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Jake:啊我会我会我会我会
Jake: Ah, I can do it, I can do it, I can do it.
Jake:来给我我会
Jake: Come on, give it to me, I can do it.
Tasha: 等等等等真的你不会
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait, you really can't.
Tasha: 好了然后你挤一圈啊
Tasha: Okay, now squeeze it all around.
Jake:好我挤一圈
Jake: Okay, I'll squeeze it all around.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mhm.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Mhm, okay.
Jake:到我了
Jake: It's my turn.
Shure: 这回服务到位吗
Shure: Is the service good this time?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 我试吃一个
Shure: I'll try one.
Lucia: 要等他把这都解完了我才能刮是吗
Lucia: Do I have to wait for him to finish unwrapping before I can scratch?
Lucia: 哈哈哈吃熟了吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it cooked?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是熟了吗
Jake: Is it cooked?
Tasha: 他拿出来了说明没熟我觉得
Tasha: He took it out, so I think it's not cooked.
Lucia: 啊那咱刚吃的呢
Lucia: Ah, then what did we just eat?
Lucia: 不知道那个感觉还行吧
Lucia: I don't know, it seemed okay.
Jake:那个感觉还行吧
Jake: It seemed okay.
Lucia: 没事反正是羊肉牛肉没有寄生虫
Lucia: No worries, at least lamb and beef don't have parasites.
Jake:这玩意是羊肉牛肉
Jake: This stuff is lamb and beef.
Jake:嗯对没错
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:怎么管
Jake: How to manage it?
Lucia: 怎么刮要不你示范一下
Lucia: How to scrape it, can you demonstrate?
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha.
小薇 ：突然觉得我手洗过了
Tasha: Suddenly I feel like my hands are clean.
Lucia: 没事反正咱一直在这做饭呢对就是
Lucia: It's okay, we've been cooking here all along, right?
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:卫生等级a
Jake: Hygiene level A.
Jake:这边是怎么分呢
Jake: How is this divided here?
Jake:卫生等级哦OK
Jake: Hygiene level, oh okay.
Lucia: 好像是有a b c啊
Lucia: It seems like there's A, B, C.
Lucia: 但是一般来说好像也无人在意
Lucia: But generally, it seems like nobody cares.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:现在好了
Jake: It's good now.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 他就像那个来上学的diy
Tasha: He looks like someone attending a DIY class.
Tasha: 蛋糕手工课
Tasha: A cake-making class.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈是吧
Shure: Haha, right?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 没问题吧
Shure: No problem, right?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 没问题这还有一个
Shure: No problem, there's another one.
Jake:还活着
Jake: It's still alive.
Shure: 这绝对熟了哈哈
Shure: This is definitely cooked, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈啥
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, oh, thanks.
Shure: 哈没有一个人敢自己放手里吃是吧
Shure: Haha, nobody dares to just eat it, right?
Jake:意思这绝对熟啊
Jake: It means it's definitely cooked.
Shure: 来喽来喽
Shure: Here it comes, here it comes.
Tasha: 我们到时候把最上面一层抹一下就行好看
Tasha: We'll just smooth the top layer later, it'll look good.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我我说你上那个来上DIY手工课了
Tasha: I said you came here for a DIY class.
Tasha: 哎还剩这么多奶油呢
Tasha: Hey, there's still so much cream left.
Tasha: 多挤点没事
Tasha: Squeeze more, it's fine.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 那要不然一会直接用来弄那个纸杯蛋
Lucia: Otherwise, we can use it for those cupcakes later.
Tasha: 然后然后你把这个边边一圈再挤一下
Tasha: And then, you can squeeze a bit around the edges to make it higher.
Tasha: 加高一下他
Tasha: Make it taller.
Lucia: 然后我们
Lucia: And then we...
Jake:我来没手了
Jake: I can't, my hands are full.
Jake:哎我去厉害
Jake: Wow, that's impressive.
Lucia: 我好饿
Lucia: I'm so hungry.
Lucia: 哈哈哈看着他觉得好想吃
Lucia: Hahaha, looking at it makes me want to eat it.
Jake:跟杜雅拿个凳子来
Jake: Go get a stool from Duya.
Lucia: 嗯没事没事我这样就行了
Lucia: Hmm, it's fine, it's fine, I'm good like this.
Jake:有有有我屋里多的很
Jake: Yes, yes, I have plenty in my room.
Lucia: 对乖
Lucia: Right, good.
Lucia: 哦那也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Jake:我的
Jake: Mine.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 原来是某些人私藏了
Lucia: So someone has been hoarding them.
Jake:对我的黑工办公室
Jake: Yeah, in my secret office.
Lucia: 那我就先鸠占鹊巢了
Lucia: Then I'll just make myself at home.
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 您再起还剩这么多奶油吗
Tasha: Do you still have this much cream left?
Jake:好来了
Jake: Alright, coming.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎你俩这个时候你来
Lucia: Hahaha, you guys come at this time.
Tasha: 哎你这怎么放啊
Tasha: Hey, how do you put this?
Jake:有救
Jake: There's hope.
Lucia: 就能把它再弄上去吗
Lucia: Can you put it back on?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 是这是是这样吗
Lucia: Is this how it works?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 对哎
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 那就是其实只用一个包也行对吧
Lucia: So actually, you only need one bag, right?
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 对好吧这蛋糕太小了
Lucia: Okay, this cake is too small.
Lucia: 没没必要那么大的
Lucia: No need for such a big one.
Jake:我觉得我怎么挤都没关系对吧
Jake: I think it doesn't matter how I squeeze it, right?
Tasha: 对但是你这不是增加人家工作量
Tasha: Yeah, but aren't you increasing their workload?
Tasha: 你再把边边一圈加高一下
Tasha: Why don't you raise the edges a bit?
Shure: 每次都抱一双新筷子
Shure: Every time I grab new chopsticks.
Shure: 然后发现哎
Shure: Then I realize, hey,
Shure: 我刚才有筷子
Shure: I already had chopsticks.
Jake:没事给下一层吧
Jake: It's okay, give it to the next layer.
Alice:大叔谢谢
Alice: Uncle, thank you.
Jake:没了是吧
Jake: It's gone, right?
Lucia: 也行反正反正会用到
Lucia: That's fine, it'll be used anyway.
Tasha: 嗯好我还挤一圈
Tasha: Okay, I'll squeeze another layer.
Jake:对好再补一补
Jake: Yeah, go ahead, add more.
Jake:哎呀没事
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Jake:好玩好玩好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun, fun, fun.
Jake:好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:真的这么多
Jake: Really, this much?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 我们
Lucia: We...
Lucia: 这个最后会不会高超过他的长宽啊
Lucia: Will this end up being taller than its length and width?
Tasha: 啊什么东西
Tasha: Huh? What?
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: This thing.
Lucia: 这个圆柱
Lucia: This cylinder.
Lucia: 体的h超过他的直径哈哈哈
Lucia: Will its height exceed its diameter? Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈OK就是他是一个长的
Jake: Hahaha, okay, so it's a tall one.
Jake:不是一个扁的
Jake: Not a flat one.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake:一个高个小蛋糕对
Jake: A tall little cake, yes.
Lucia:  对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Lucia: 那样就会有点不太好切
Lucia: That way it will be a bit hard to cut.
Lucia: 就是切了之后就容易倒
Lucia: It will easily topple after cutting.
Lucia: 没事管他呢
Lucia: No worries, whatever.
Shure: 要学吗
Shure: Do you want to learn?
Jake:这汉堡挺好哈哈哈
Jake: This burger is pretty good, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命
Lucia: Hahaha, help!
Lucia: 这边稍微有点这边稍微有点矮
Lucia: This side is slightly lower.
Lucia: 就是这边高一点这边矮一点
Lucia: This side is a bit higher, this side is lower.
Tasha: 我给他刮一下把这拖上去
Tasha: I'll scrape it a bit to level it up.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:不是主要这个表面很像汉堡
Jake: The main thing is that the surface really looks like a burger.
Jake:要点肉我要
Jake: I need some meat, I want...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈甜
Lucia: Hahaha, sweet.
Lucia: 都是咸的你不觉得很奇怪吗
Lucia: It's all salty, don't you think it's weird?
Jake:我要干嘛我要干嘛
Jake: What am I doing, what am I doing?
Tasha: 再挤一圈
Tasha: Squeeze another round.
Jake:再挤一圈
Jake: Squeeze another round.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:对这个应该就是区别于汉堡的
Jake: Yes, this should differentiate it from a burger.
Lucia: 圈
Lucia: Round.
Jake:最重要的一层对
Jake: The most important layer, yes.
Lucia: 这这外围
Lucia: This, this outer edge...
Jake:我等会我捋一捋我
Lucia: 这个你小心别把他吊在这个上面
Lucia: Be careful not to hang it on this thing.
Jake:捋一捋
Jake: Just let me sort it out.